ciao a tutti
mi piacerebbe iniziare questo dialogo
con voi ponendomi una domanda vi siete
mai chiesti cosa rappresenta la
creatività cos'è la creatività cosa
alimenta cosa l'alimentano veramente
alla fantasia ecco al giorno d'oggi
nonostante ci siano enormi studi a
riguardo mi sento ancora parlare come se
fosse una condizione innata c'è chi
nasce creativo e chi no ci sono
discipline dove vengono del viene
applicata la fantasia creatività la
fantasia e altre dove non viene
assolutamente toccata scalfita
ecco vorrei fare con voi un gioco
usando proprio questi punti che se ve lo
stesse chiedendo sono 21 però non è
importante la quantità quello che vi
chiedo di fare è di provare ad
immaginare una possibile relazione una
connessione tra questi punti
senza ovviamente
rinchiudersi no nello schema della linea
che unisce contino per pontino ma
provare a farsi guidare dalla propria
fantasia quindi dalla propria
potenzialità della mente di creare una
relazione tra questi punti
ecco ovviamente non possiamo farlo
praticamente immagino che è difficile
anche riuscire ad immaginarli però vi do
qualche esempio
ad esempio possiamo provare ad unire i
punti attraverso delle linee spezzate
attraverso delle circonferenze
attraverso
appunto delle curve che magari si
uniscono in un in un asse centrale
queste queste unioni queste relazioni
che siamo in grado di creare con i punti
possono generare anche una potenzialità
di immaginari visibili
completamente diciamo
quantitativamente infinita perché ognuno
di noi è in grado di vedere qualcosa di
diverso in queste immagini ad esempio io
della prima vedo una cartina stradale
una mappa di strade che si intrecciano
tra di loro e delle persone o qualche
unità che passa attraverso queste strade
nella seconda magari ecco viene da
pensare ad un sistema solare dei pianeti
che girano intorno delle orbiter oppure
un insieme di forze no una forza che
spinge dal basso che da arriva dall'alto
o un sistema vegetativo cioè unendo i
punti in una centrale ha subito natura
perché è il processo della natura ecco
quello che vi sto mostrando in realtà fa
parte di un libro che si chiama viaggio
nella fantasia di bruno munari un libro
propedeutico per bambini
io spero che molti di voi conoscano
bruno munari per innumerevoli contributi
che ha portato non soltanto al mondo
della diciamo della delle arti visive ma
anche a quello della pedagogia perché
alla base del pensiero di bruno munari
c'era la concezione che la creatività e
la fantasia
fossero dei percorsi mentali che
costituiscono la natura dell'essere
umano e quindi come la memoria
attraverso la memoria siamo in grado
anche di elaborare dei processi creativi
ognuno di noi è in grado di farlo
semplicemente siccome anche la memoria
sappiamo che va in qualche modo allenata
no perché soprattutto al giorno d'oggi
in cui siamo abbiamo questi
sostituti della memoria che in qualche
modo ci aiutano nel ricordare le nostre
cose quotidiane per la realtà è un
palliativo perché la nostra memoria non
viene alimentata grazie all'utilizzo
degli smartphone quindi alimentare la
nostra memoria e vale a dire anche
alimentare la potenzialità di un
utilizzo creativo della nostra memoria
perché secondo munari la memoria appunto
è in grado di
farci
interiorizzati di dati non farceli
farli entrare a far parte di noi e poi
attraverso le relazioni che siamo in
grado di stabilire da questi dati che
siamo chiesti riusciamo a creare dei
processi creativi in grado di generare
nuove idee nuovi concetti nuove immagini
ecco io ho conosciuto morali quando
avevo 18 anni venivo da degli studi
scientifici quindi non mi ero mai in
realtà fa d'entrata nel mondo della
creatività
nonostante versi venissi da una famiglia
di persone molto creative una volta che
sono entrate in contatto con queste con
queste concezioni il mio modo di vedere
le cose e di percepire la vita che mi
circondava e cambiato completamente e ho
capito che avrei voluto passare la mia
vita a cercare tutti i modi possibili in
cui poter sviluppare la mia creatività e
metterla in atto e allo stesso tempo
alimentarla attraverso la conoscenza
quindi ho cominciato a studiare design
cominciato a lavorare in vari laboratori
e tra queste varie sperimentazioni sono
entrata in contatto prima un po per
gioco e poi per grande passione nel
mondo del tatuaggio che in realtà è
proprio quello di cui vorrei parlarvi
oggi perché a fare il mio detto tutto
intorno ad un concerto fondamentale è
proprio quello di questo derby 06 il
contatto allora
[Musica]
vorrei fare una piccola premessa perché
ovviamente diciamo il mondo del
tatuaggio mondo talmente tanto
eterogeneo che sarebbe impossibile
parlare di tutte le diciamo declinazione
di gusto per citare dorfles quindi mi
limiterò a parlare del mio modo di
concepire il tatuaggio e spero quello di
altre persone il mio primo tatuaggio è
stato al 19 anni
una mattina mi sono svegliata e sapete
quando dormite una posizione molto
scomoda non per tutta la notte e poi il
giorno dopo vi svegliate con delle
piazze sul corpo rosse per chi ha la
pelle sensibile può capirmi e quella
mattina mi sono guardato allo specchio e
avevo questa piazza rossa non meno
identificata che ha detto agli occhi di
tutti era un piccione però io a vederla
con un po più di romanticismo ci vedevo
proprio una rondine ecco in quel momento
io ero a roma e stavo affrontando un
periodo un po complicato e difficile
della mia vita non riuscivo e non volevo
tirare fuori dei concetti che avevo
dentro delle delle sensazioni e delle
emozioni negative e io mi sembrerà
strano però alla vista di quella forma
non identificata la vista di quel di
quella forma visiva è come se fossi
riuscita ad esse realizzare un concetto
che avevo dentro e che non riuscivo a
tirar fuori quelle parole attraverso
proprio l'immagine allora ci ho messo
tre settimane per convincere gli altri
che si trattasse di una rondine non di
un piccione e alterità ante per
convincere i miei genitori del suo
significato trascendentale tanto da
volerlo appunto imprimere per sempre
sulla mia pelle e quindi cosa era
riuscito a fare attraverso questo primo
tatuaggio non solo abbiamo creato avevo
era passata per un rito di iniziazione
no perché ero sempre farà tratta dei
tatuaggi ma non avevo mai provato il
nesso il collegamento da poter fare per
spingermi in questo mondo ero riuscita a
creare appunto una connessione nel tra
un concerto astratto un concetto mentale
e
il mio corpo il mio modo di essere al
mondo avevo creato una narrazione
personale attraverso la mia pelle in
grado di mettermi su un piano diverso di
comunicazione con me stessa e con gli
altri
spesso tendiamo a pensare siamo portati
a pensare che la pelle sia un po là
diciamo la parte più superficiale di noi
stessi non siano involucro che qualche
modo appunto chi tra giovane in base
alla propria bella e proprio corpo fa
delle associazioni superficiali
ecco il professor bertirotti ci ha
ricordato proprio fare non si può
pensare corpo senza la mente mente al
corpo il corpo e mente come diceva anche
alda merini a pelle si sentono delle
cose a cui le parole non sanno dare un
nome non so se vi è mai capitato di
incontrare qualcuno no di provare
all'inizio delle sensazioni di empatia
di attrazione o di repulsione di rabbia
di odio ecco queste sensazioni in realtà
derivano dal nostro bagaglio arcaico
della natura sono come delle porte di
reazioni istintive che noi abbiamo delle
terminati stimoli che vengono
dall'esterno
finalizzate alla nostra sopravvivenza
con questo ovviamente non voglio dire
che tutte le prime impressioni siano
quelli che contano siamo le più giuste
voglio semplicemente farvi riflettere
sul valore che assume il nostro corpo
come confine tra il nostro infinito e e
il mondo che ci circonda
come
uno specchio dei nostri cambiamenti
delle nostre la nostra vita del nostro
essere al mondo e in qualche modo è
proprio attraverso il corpo che noi
richiediamo gli stimoli che ci fanno
sentire vivi e che ci fanno sentire
anche in armonia con il mondo che ci
circonda
ed è proprio in questo confine quello
della pelle del nostro corpo che il
tatuaggio può instaurarsi come un
racconto è come un autodeterminazione
delle proprie volontà del proprio essere
allora il tatuaggio è diciamo un
linguaggio da un linguaggio del nostro
corpo che in realtà fa parte della
storia dell'uomo fin da quando abbiamo
memoria pensate che il primo l'uomo più
antico e dalle ferie foto ritrovato
sulla terra a 61 tatuaggi quindi capiamo
bene che diciamo non è questione di
appunto di mode si sicuramente adesso
sarà cambiato con il tempo perché
ovviamente avendo accompagnato la storia
dell'uomo anche declinandosi in bar in
base ai valori culturali dell'epoca in
cui passava e dei valori simbolici e
passando da punto dal dall'essere
una una sorta di obbligo culturale
pensiamo alle tribù maori fino ad
arrivare
diciamo un po poco tempo fa quando era
identificazione di
uno stato sociale tirato fuori dal dalla
società una sorta di identificazione
all'interno di strutture
che
marginali
poi appunto adesso con la trasformazione
culturale degli ultimi anni si è sempre
più associato alla parola moda che
sicuramente secondo me non è un concetto
sbagliato perché la moda cos'è non è
nient'altro che la rappresentazione
visiva di una cultura e allo stesso modo
è la diciamo il veicolo espressivo più
rapido che io posso avere per comunicare
qualcosa voi per comunicare la mia
immagine vuoi io adesso sono vestita qui
però che l'idea di avrei dato se fossi
minuto in pigiama per dirvi allo stesso
modo il tatuaggio anch'esso è un veicolo
espressivo molto rapido perché cambia
appunto il mio modo di narrare be me
stessa perché se ci riflettiamo la
narrazione personale non può essere
identificati non può essere diciamo
[Musica]
unicità aria perché noi siamo quello che
siamo
grazie anche alla nostra cultura noi
siamo la nostra identità perché facciamo
parte di un brodo culturale della
diciamo di una società per cui non è
possibile pensare a diciamo una
affermazione di sé stessi slegata dal
dagli altri è sempre un racconto che in
qualche modo
connette connette noi stessi e le altre
persone e creando due livelli di
narrazione da un lato una relazione che
vi può cambiare
durante il percorso perché i tatuaggi
non sono in arrivo possono anche
rappresentare in arrivo ma tante volte
tatuaggi rappresentano un punto di
partenza possono rappresentare un modo
diverso di vedere le cose e possono
rappresentare uno stimolo per farti
cambiare punto di vista e farti vedere
te stesso e gli altri sotto un'altra
chiave di lettura
parliamo proprio del tatuaggio in
termini tecnici pratici nodi di contatto
umano
quindi parliamo di dolore e di
sofferenza pellicone di sangue perché
comunque sono fanno parte di questa
pratica
ecco tante volte tanto i miei colleghi
che
hanno paura degli aghi e magari quando
vanno a fare il prelievo del sangue
vengono eppure durante la pratica del
tatuaggio
sembra proprio che questo dolore riesca
in qualche modo a sancire una sorta di
rinascita personale
da da un momento da una difficoltà e
come se si riuscisse a trasformare un
emozione negativa ea valorizzare
l'emozione positiva che noi cambiamo con
quella negativa e quindi è un po come
appunto nelle popolazioni arcaiche
quando il tatuaggio sicuramente era una
tecnica molto più dolorosa però
rappresentava proprio il rito di
passaggio tra un età infantile mela
l'unità come se appunto fosse una vera e
propria prova di forza
e quindi attraverso anche il dolore che
riusciamo ad entrare di comunicazione
con noi stessi e con
con una storia un racconto
racconto che decidiamo di narrare di
dell'oss trendy della nostra
individualità
però questo racconto come dicevo prima
non è non è un racconto univoco è un
racconto che in qualche modo unisce
la mia i miei valori culturali a quelli
dell'altra persona
il mio mestiere è proprio questo è
quello di entrare a far parte dentro di
me a di sentirmi parte delle storie che
mi vengono raccontate delle emozioni che
mi vengono trasmesse e delle sensazioni
e delle di tutto di più di tutte le
diciamo le i valori no che una persona
vuole rappresentare per per narrare del
di se stesso del proprio della propria
vita e io attraverso questo contatto che
genero con le persone sono in grado di
vivere delle cose che forse nella mia
sola vita non avrei mai potuto fare e
quindi la vera la vera bellezza del pat
maggio proprio quello hai fatto di
scusate è il fatto di qualche modo unire
nei propri la propria individualità e
entrar a far parte di un linguaggio
sociale e creativo perché è proprio
attraverso la nostra le nostre
interazioni attraverso il contatto che
si genera anche semplicemente da
dall'ascolto io comincio il mio processo
creativo cominciò il mio lavoro da
tatuatrice proprio attraverso il
l'azione dell'ascoltare quindi il
sentire che non è un sentire
aprire le orecchie è un sentire motivo è
un entrare nella testa dell'altro e
provare ad entrare la terza dell'altra
persona e provare a capire perché quella
per sa cosa sta provando quella persona
ed è solo attraverso questa connessione
emotiva che siamo in grado di generare
un'immagine generare una
rappresentazione quindi per concludere
quello che vorrei che vorrei dirvi è
proprio questo è fatto ricordate 21
punti all'inizio tutte queste storie che
si intrecciano e che entrano a far parte
di un racconto comune non sono
nient'altro che i punti di cui parlavamo
prima
punti che magari mistico lì non possono
sembrare niente però se noi attraverso
un po di esercizio un pò di fantasia un
po di creatività proviamo a metterli in
relazione tra di loro sono sicura che
saremo in grado di generare da questi
punti mille storie nuove e diverse e
magari mille nuove idee ecco questo è
stato il mio secondo tatuaggio i 21
punti di munari proprio perché quello
che vorrei condividere e trasmettere a
voi oggi è il fatto che non dobbiamo
pensare di non essere in grado non
dobbiamo pensare di fermarci appunto
alla partenza
dobbiamo capire e
è questione semplicemente di connettere
i nostri punti e di metterli insieme e
di giocare con loro
un po come
un po come diceva anche steve jobs nel
suo discorso a stanford parlava proprio
di puntini dicendo che raccontando le
sue esperienze di vita e dicendo che a
un certo punto questi puntini ci sono
uniti ecco quello che voglio trasmettere
via di avere fiducia che in qualsiasi
scelta voi prendiate nella vita questi
puntini prima o poi se ci giocate
riusciranno ad unirsi e la casa
importante quindi è avere coscienza di
quello che si fa e
farlo anche con un'ottica rimanendo
infatti con po infantile nel saggio
pensando sempre che in realtà essere
adulti non vuol dire smettere di giocare
ma
[Musica]
con conoscere e giocare può essere la
chiave che ci mette cifra mente le
relazioni con le nostre esperienze la
nostra vita ci può aprire la strada a
qualcosa di nuovo di diverso
[Applauso]